this is the biggest chapter of Hunter
Hunter yet legitimately this is bigger
than the return of hisoka because
tagashi is now beginning to end
questions that have been lingering for
quite literally two decades we've seen
karapika's story and now this is the
B-side of the curta massacre including a
massive character Revelation that I
never even came close to suspecting as
well as connections that will blow you
away and most importantly why the death
of the Phantom troop is now practically
set in stone I had to take a lot of time
with this chapter because you don't
quite get the full scale of it with just
one read this chapter made me go back
and read other parts of Hunter Hunter
because it's starting to link so much
together and this is definitely my
favorite chapter by far of the new batch
and it starts in an interesting place
giving us a meeting between the mafia
factions and the serratic squad which
kind of came out of nowhere to me but
it's really emphasizing the everybody vs
Miranda factional divide that's
happening on the lower tears which is
exciting because I'm honestly far more
interested in the Haley family than I am
like any of the princes but now I also
have this profound feeling of dread that
I've only ever felt once before in the
series and that was when nefepito was
born during the antok I think we're at a
turning point with the Hailey family and
the troop emphasized this by discovering
one of their hidey holes and giving them
a shocking amount of credit the idea
that there's something deeply unsettling
about this group being able to detect
The Troop and act accordingly because
being real the Chimera ants didn't
really start out as a threat I mean they
were just piles and piles of fodder for
quite some time but then they reached a
critical point where they became not
just a threat but like the center of a
dread Galaxy and all I'm saying is this
feels very familiar right now with the
Haley family it's also not a great sign
that this panel of the Phantom troop has
the number four behind them because in
Japanese number four is often associated
with death as it can be read as she
which also means to die so taken in a
certain way death is currently stalking
thinks Nobunaga and vaitan I honestly
would not be surprised if one or even
all of them died at this point because
it would give us a sort of Pito kite
style situation where we now have to
take this main enemy seriously because
they've killed off an established
Powerhouse quick visual note I
absolutely love this panel of feitan
it's very odd to see something like this
in manga with this ridiculous amount of
negative space around it but I love that
we just focus in on a sliver of hyper
detailed feitan getting the perspective
of what the guy is seeing through the
doorway but another big death flag is
the idea of the Phantom troop flashback
because as amazing as it is this this is
looking real bad for them we'll put that
aside for one moment though because this
flashback is wild so many questions
answered but also so many new questions
asked and the whole thing has this
overall distinct Bittersweet flavor to
it especially when we see characters
like pakunoda uvogen and shalnak who
have long since departed this world
bakunoda in particular was quite
difficult to read in the best way
possible as a child Togashi has this way
of drawing her with such vibrant life
which particularly comes across through
her eyes as opposed to what was the more
modern parkinoda who looks significantly
more weighed down by the world in her
experiences this answered a key question
about York New City though at the end of
that Arc pakunoda shot up six troop
members with the memory bomb and I guess
the reason why she chose Finks and shaan
Target even though they weren't founding
members was because they were childhood
friends this chapter also makes an
effort to highlight a special connection
between crolo and poconoda very sweet
but also very very not that knowing what
happens in the future and they also just
realized that I don't think we ever saw
crolo's reaction to discovering that
parkinora had died however we did get
his incredibly depressed reaction to
Sherlock's death and seeing them
together as kids really does make that
hit a lot harder especially since along
with Franklin Shannock appears to have
been one of the original crawler friend
Trio I love seeing the initial group
divisions in general though for example
Finks and feitan they are they are a
perfect doer and feitan's younger design
was by far my favorite it's amazing just
like the hair man the hair which also
applies to things that that was pretty
amazing as well but a grouping I did not
expect was Machi and uvgin because off
the top of my head I don't really recall
the dynamic within the troop so it makes
me want to go back and reread York New
City to see if there's anything I missed
or forgot when it comes to over again I
think I tend to associate him more
closely with Nobunaga and speaking of no
binaga
nowhere to be seen in this flashback
which I find funny because he's the one
who started it he's all like hey guys
remember when we were young because I do
even though I wasn't there when it comes
to Franklin I think this chapter is the
most emotion we've seen out of him in in
well ever it's similar to poconoda
really Franklin these days is quiet
Samba and has a very realist dystopian
view of the world depending on your own
personal perspective so basically what
we're seeing here is the corruption of
the truth because right now in this
moment they're completely innocent which
I think means that we should prepare
ourselves for some pretty intense trauma
coming very very soon the way the
chapter ends is quite unusual for a
Shona manga because it's not like a huge
Cliffhanger or dramatic something or
other that leaves a question it's
literally just crolo and Friends of
crawler having fun dubbing anime which
is that's definitely not expected and
the ending sat weirdly with me for a
while but I think that this is Togashi
giving crawler this one last moment of
Happiness before everything goes to [ __ ]
which is unusually merciful of tagashi
and now we do have hints about how said
[ __ ] is going going to occur with the
whole child kidnapping subplot and here
is an interesting potential connection
this could be jumping the gun but one of
the kidnappers shown looks quite a bit
like seradnick's tattoo artist who was
also a previous member of the Haley
family I bring that up because right now
Hunter Hunter looks like it's forming a
sort of narrative triangle between
karapika the Phantom troop and seradnik
right now every key element seems to
revolve around one of those three
triangular thick parties even the hail
leased up because of their connection to
the prince and because the troop have
become involved lost the radnik did end
up with the bulk of the Scarlet eyes and
almost certainly Pyro's head so this
story could be playing out in a way
where all three of these groups were
connected long long ago and this is the
fatesome climactic outcome something
very bad is going to happen which is
probably an understatement and my fear
is that that very bad thing is going to
happen to one of the two girls that we
meet specifically the one named sarasa
because there is no other record of her
in the series to my knowledge the other
girl however we actually know her quite
well you may or may not recognize her
but this is Sheila and the reason why
you may not recognized her is because
she only appeared in volume zero which
are the two chapters that cover
krupika's backstory leading up to the
curta massacre karapika and Pyro found
Sheila lost in the forest with an
injured leg and actually if you look
closely in this chapter Sheila also
appears to have a leg injury so it's
like a permanent thing that she that she
just has and it's also heavily implied
at the end of volume zero that Sheila is
the one who discovered the curta
massacre but this completely flips that
perspective on its head because now that
Sheila is the confirmed childhood friend
of the Phantom Troupe her role could be
a lot more Sinister in fact she may even
be one of the two missing troop members
that we've never met the original number
four and the original number eight one
of them was killed by Silva and the
other was replaced by hisoka and now we
don't count on mokage because he's not
canon in fact we try to forget the
hunter hunter movies exist in general
Sheila even has that very same book in
karapika's flashback which is about a
hunter and Sheila's dream is to become a
professional Hunter she then gave that
book to krapika Empire which is what
eventually leads the Kurt to Elder to
let krapika go out into the out outside
world basically long story last long
karapika would have been killed in the
curta massacre if not for Sheila and her
role in this could really go either way
Sheila could still be a completely
innocent passerby or she herself could
be very much involved with the massacre
either way her presence here is massive
completely unexpected and I cannot
predict what direction tagashi is going
to take her meanwhile the videotape
theme might seem a bit random in this
chapter but it's a call back to chapter
1002 where we see a flashback of the
troop as kids with this unknown
videotape which and this is no
exaggeration people have been theorizing
about for the last 20 years one kind of
out there idea was that this is the
chapter black videotape from togashi's
previous series Yu hakusha which would
explain the sudden pessimistic turn the
Phantom troop took you know seeing all
the horrific necesses of mankind kinda
makes you want to destroy it but there's
also this big web of theories that
Hunter Hunter takes place in the same
universe as you hakusha I don't
personally subscribe to it and we're not
gonna get into it here but this
videotape has been one of the the most
perplexing Mysteries of the entire
Series so to have it solved in such a
sweet way it's quite satisfying and what
we're seeing play out right now is a
story that Togashi has had in mind since
the beginning where at the very least
into your new city I should say but in
volume zero he quite famously stated
that it was his intention to draw two
sides of the kurta massacre story side a
was completed in volume zero with
kropica's perspective and tagashi had
every intention to do a side B with the
troop's perspective but and I quote A
lot happened so I had to shelve it the
next couple of chapters or even maybe
the next chapter itself may very well
show us why the troop massacred the go
to Clan and I don't think that
interested is quite a word enough to
describe how I feel about this because
either way it is going to be very
difficult to pull off for example will
Togashi try to humanize the troop more
or will he try to demonize them more
because there was something nice about
leaving it as a question mark with no
definitive answer because if we go with
humanizing the truth then how do you
possibly even begin to justify genocide
even if there's a huge twist thing that
occurs like say the cursor Clan is
somehow involved in all of the child
trafficking which which may be the case
because the troop did leave a note with
the meteor City motto we'll accept
anything you leave here but don't ever
take anything away from us implying that
the Curt Clan did did that thing and
took something away from him and then
there's also the whole only life can pay
for Life part of the medial city law so
maybe the Kurt's Clan weren't exactly
the Paragon of Innocence that we thought
they were but that would be such a wild
and hard to sell twist and even then I
don't think there's a way to justify the
troop's actions so we're walking a very
very thin tightrope here and on the
other hand if we're heading towards
demonizing them more then it puts a huge
burden on the aspect of what inevitably
corrupted them it needs to be something
pretty damn big to take them from these
delightful innocent kidlets to well
effectively war criminals so again I
think we should very much brace for the
worst I'm hoping that the tattoo guy
does turn out to be the same one who
works for seradnik and that the fourth
Prince has a deeper story wedge between
the troop and karapika because it would
just tie this whole succession War stuff
together very very neatly and looks
saranic is the one who ended up with the
bulk of the Scarlet eyes as well as the
head so he may have had some sort of
first choice preference here we could
even end up in like a weird three-way
scenario like kropica of a scroller vs
redneck well maybe even crolo and
kropica could team up and uh that's
probably not gonna happen but child
crawler is quite the sight to behold all
of the joy of gone mixed with the
intellectual potential of karapika and
the parallels between crolo and karapika
have always been incredibly strong what
would the whole genius growing up in
societies persecuted by the greater
World thing but that aside I'm really
glad that Togashi is finally getting the
opportunity to tell a story that he's
wanted to tell for two decades even if
it does make me feel very nervous for
the imminent future of the troop to be
fair we've known that something like
this has been coming for a long time in
the volume zero interview tagashi did
Pretty straightforwardly State in
regards to krapika and the troop they
will all die but I guess now that it's
finally here I'm just feeling somewhat
reluctant to let these characters go
however if there's anything I've learned
about stories over the last lifetime of
consuming them it's that heartfelt
flashback backs are often used to
tenderize our impressions of characters
in order to make their eventual deaths
hit that much harder and I think that
Hunter Hunter is about to hit us pretty
damn hard